We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two David Pakman.
The man called in to tell us what he thinks
a Putin vs. Biden debate would look like.
Take a listen.
Hi, Dave. I will sum up a Biden Putin debate.
Yeah, Biden. I fired people for smoking marijuana
a long time ago. Putin I murdered people and put
them in the gulag for smoking marijuana day. I'm
so upset. But what Biden is doing and I'll tell
you that I can't wait until he's gone. And Kamala
Harris feels so guilty about putting so many
African-Americans in prison for marijuana that she
finally federally legalizes it. I don't think it's
going to happen until she becomes president.
I hope the right wingers are right that Biden
is just holding her spot for a little while
and he just step down already. Saulo brother.
All right. So the Eggman, very, very aggressive
there and always, always weighing in, Shulem,
to the eggman on today's bonus show, the latest
plan from Lewis Dejoy to keep making the post
office even worse. Can Biden get them out before
he does it? We will also talk about a report that
the richest Americans may be underreporting
their incomes by as much as 20 percent. And
Trump was right about something. Trump predicted
that news ratings would tank if he was gone.
That has happened, although some of it is
just the cyclical nature of people tuning out
after elections. We will talk about corporate
media ratings on today's bonus show as well.
Don't miss it. Join Pakman Dotcom, get instant
access to the bonus show as The David Pakman Show.